[Music]
here's how i imagined
losing my mother would go
i would be by her side through the final
days
attending to every need
i would tell her i loved her when it was
time
i would say a prayer as she floated away
before assembling the family for a
stately funeral
bedecked with her favorite flowers
i would be soft but steely
raw but ready pained
but prepared
here's what actually happened i got a
call in the middle of an interview that
my mother had a stroke
then spent 30 hours on a plane from
california to karachi arranging for a
ventilator
while my mother heaved her final few
breaths i found out she was already dead
when i walked out of the airport
stood confused inside a morgue refusing
to recognize her frozen body
then when the house was nearly empty i
went into my mother's room
and i searched for her i searched
on her bed under her bed in the bathroom
behind the curtains behind the doors
and when i did not find her i dissolved
into a heap
screaming for her so violently that my
uncle who lived next door
ran over to hold me as i shook with
sorrow greater than anything
my body could hold
i didn't want to wake up or
keep going but i chose a grave
i kissed my mother's face for the last
time before covering it with a white
sheet
and i got back on a plane to resume my
mba
everyone congratulated me for holding up
well
and i inferred that holding up well at
least publicly
was the thing to do
everyone also moved on from my mother's
death
everyone but me
dwindled flowers wilted just as my
post-funeral adrenaline
began to fade there were no more
logistics no more
decisions no more questions except for
what the hell
was wrong with me my heart
thundered at every phone ring expecting
more bad news
my brain was blanketed in fog my throat
was so tight
that breathing felt labored now i'm the
kind of person who has a back-up plan
for her back-up plan and
i had no patience for this lethargy this
obliviousness and i decided
i was going to get over grief i hunted
down
medical journals self-help books essays
and i began diagnosing myself
i discovered that when i was drifting
listlessly
hours after my mother's death unable to
feel
i was in phase one of grief numbness
a narcotic regression of sorts as my
brain tried to absorb the blow
when i was calling for my mother in our
home after seeing
her corpse in the morgue or following
butterflies and birds around stanford in
case she had sent them my way
i was in phase two of grief
yearning and searching
my constant chokehold was globus
pharyngeus
my fear of phone calls was anticipatory
grief
an attempt by my brain and body never to
be caught
off guard again my instinct
to flee my own home when my roommate
innocently draped
our bathtub with a shower curtain
because i thought i was back in the
morgue and there was a dead body beneath
this white sheet too
that was grief induced ptsd
grief it turned out was a bottomless
inferno
desecrating my body and mind
grief it turned out was chronic i would
never
get over grief i would never get my
mother back i would never stop wanting
my mother back
grief was there to god damn stay
why then weren't more people around me
talking about
grief when did we start censoring this
ubiquitous inevitable monster
well there is actually an answer to my
semi-rhetorical question
the censorship of grief began in the
middle of the 20th century according to
sociologist jeffrey gorrer
because of two big shifts in society the
dawn of the hospital
as a place for the dying and the growing
conviction that life should be
above all happy
by 1950 the sight of death had been
displaced
from the home to the hospital until then
people usually died in their own bed
surrounded by loved ones
but with modern medicine families began
handing over responsibility for their
dying
to hospitals we entered an era
of medicalized death or as philip aries
calls it forbidden death where it was
suddenly possible to purge our homes and
avert our eyes
from the shocking extinguishing of
consciousness
that's exactly what we did especially
after normal peels 1952 book
the power of positive thinking
catapulted us down
a decades-long inexhaustible well of
optimism
by the 70s we were vying for endless
economic growth
and limitless life optimization by the
90s
the american psychology association had
termed sadness
and pessimism as learned behaviors by
2006
rhonda byrne's popular book the secret
claimed that a universal law of
attraction
materially rewards positive thinking
our voracious appetite for positivity
and productivity
together with the segregation of homes
and hospitals along lines of life and
death
relegated grief into obscurity
sadness was voluntary
death was invisible
we were forever joyous
young immortal
except we are not
every 26 seconds someone
dies of covet 19 in america
the most powerful affluent economy in
the entire world
fifteen americans have died of kovid 19
since i started talking today death is
so inescapable
that we drift in and out of varying
degrees of lockdown depending on just
how many people have died of late
we could continue segregating ourselves
into those who can turn away from grief
and those who are drowning in it doctors
nurses funeral workers nursing homes
brief families
or we could recognize
the realities of grief
we could recognize that grief isn't
meant to be heroic
and calling doctors and nurses
superhuman for sacrificing everything in
the face of this virus
denies them basic human empathy
we could recognize that grief is doled
out disproportionately
to the already marginalized compared to
white americans
black native and hispanic americans are
three times more likely to die
of coven 19.
we could recognize that grief is not
just mental
it is physical too the grieving
lose appetite memory oxygen sleep
they forget how to read and drive they
get strange ear infections from unshed
tears
we could recognize that grief is not
meant to be
something you bounce back from and for
10 to 20 percent of us
grief turns pathological pulling us into
long-term depression
unless we get mental health support
we could recognize that grief is not
meant to be bottled up
and telling those who are grieving that
we are holding up well
can feel coercive a demand that we
suffer in silence without interrupting
the enjoyment of others
we could recognize our own agency to
support the grieving by asking them
questions about the ones that they lost
creating rituals in their memory marking
death
anniversaries the way we do birthdays
and weddings
we could recognize that grief demands
time but 49 out of 50 u.s
states have no bereavement leave and the
federal family medical leave act
which gives us 12 weeks off when we care
for an ailing relative
doesn't give us a single day off if they
die
after losing my mother i resented
feeling like
i had been yanked away from my own life
uprooted undone
i couldn't wrap my mind around the
breathtaking finality
of death death felt like an anomaly
i now know death is not an anomaly
death is the usual order of the universe
i now know grief is not
shameful grief is just another form of
love
grief should not be censored
no form of censorship has ever really
been effective
so i'm here today standing before you
talking about my darkest days
i'm here today asking you to make room
for the grieving i'm here today
asking you to make room
for grief